[Applaudissements]
marie miss ford qui est quand même élu
il faut le rappeler depuis 1977 sur ce
territoire et lui tout juste garder ce
temps à saint clément
elle était conseillère municipale elle
était adjointe elle a été une fois merle
est débattue elle a été député pendant
dix ans elle était vice-présidente de la
région pedersen lamassiaude ou non les
faire rayonner notre territoire et pour
faire en sorte qu'on bénéficie de cette
proximité rien vous parlez délinquance
lesieu au 12ème une famille de
l'intérieur monsieur odoul attendait que
d'autres championne 2 devienne
présidente de la république qu'elle vous
nomme comment ministre de l'intérieur et
s'est acharnée contre la mjc dont qui
faisait un très très gros travail un
travail très intéressant pour la culture
pour tous donc tout ça ça permet aussi
au débat démocratique
aujourd'hui je suis désolé madame x vous
n'êtes pas la maire de la ville de san
jet la mère du centre ville de sens pour
le front de la sécurité
marie louise fort on s'est vraiment
marie-louise faible parce qu'elle a
échoué sur tous je pense que je vais
rentrer malheureusement ce boulet c'est
les sénonais qui le subissent et qui le
traîne au quotidien et vous le boulot
jerry biret retombe repart des chèvres
bateau par des moutons faudrait
peut-être réviser un peu rentrer me
poser n'importe quoi problème de
l'animation remettre de la vie
culturelle ça c'est sûr c'est sans doute
pas votre programme me fait au doux sans
2020 ses sens 2000 rien qu'est-ce que
vous incarnez maintenant vous avez le
sens de la formule
on doit la divatte plateau resté en
place le temps de la fin de l'émission
bonne soirée au revoir et bonne soirée à
tous